if you like entertainment you want him
to run because here's what howard stern
just said howard stern just made a bold
prediction about donald trump's 2024 run
this is a the list story during a recent
episode of his hit series on series xm
shows stern floated the idea running for
2024 against donald trump the
well-respected interviewer equipped that
he is primarily primed to totally beat
his ass in fact stern considers running
against trump his civic duty he said
since it means potentially stopping a
controversial
politician from securing a second term i
would just sit there and play that
effing clip of him trying to fix the
election over and over again stern said
referring to the now infamous call trump
made to brad attempting to talk to the
georgia secretary of state into
engineering proof of election fraud and
it's on his behalf there's no way i'd
lose during co-host robin quivers said
agreed and said if trump decides to run
again you have to run against him you
can't leave it to the democrats
interesting you think stern would run
you think this is just one of those
gibberish stuff that he's talking about
yeah he's talking head and he does what
talking heads do and you know i will say
this howard stern has become completely
irrelevant by choice there's a serious
problem with him i think i guarantee you
sirius has serious regrets about
re-upping his contract last year he
doesn't want to be there you know he
took the summer off he took june july
august off he took it off he got it into
his contract he is so bitter he he's so
fearful his his stick is so old right
now and i'm a huge howard stern fan and
i guarantee you if you ask any howard
stern fan out there right now they're
not into it anymore because he's just so
bitter he's so angry he never leaves his
house in the hamptons he's so
disconnected from everything that's
going on this worked in the 90s when he
was going to run for governor and he
said something like this he'd get a real
rally but right now he's just saying it
because he's out of material so i'm
having dinner with marvin and d del
valle in l.a at palau's winning
and conversation comes about trump he's
asking do you think trump's going to run
and i gave him my feedback on what i
think is going to happen
and he says you know what's my biggest
concern about trump i said what's that
he says trump used to sell the dream
okay he used to excite he used to sell
the dream he used to say america is this
america is that america is this and he
says for whatever reason over the years
he got so bitter and it was only about
going against the people and you know
just being animosity berating all these
enemies and all this stuff i said you
know what it reminded me of he said what
i said if anybody in trump's camp here's
this you may want to consider this
although there's not a lot to be
considered but
if you do consider this here's what i
would say
say you have a team of 100 sales guys
that work for you okay if you've got 100
sales guys that was a lot of people
having sex on the floor yeah if they're
under 25 for sure so that office would
need to be sponsored by trojan but let's
just say you do have an office of 100
sales people okay here's what the
demographic's going to look like out of
your 100 sales guys one of them is going
to be the dominator that's beating and
crushing everybody that example that
everybody gets annoyed because he or she
makes more money than everybody else by
mile
they're gonna have four or five top
performers okay
that are stars but not the superstar
they're gonna have 10 people that are
doing good okay then you got the middle
people that are like showing up they're
not consistent they're inconsistent but
the same way you have the one guy that's
a super true believer in you you have
the one guy that cannot stand you
despises you every word you say he just
hangs on that to use it during lunch to
tell the guys did you hear what tom said
did you hear what tom said this is why
tom's not a good leader we should go
work somewhere else right and then you
have about 10 complainers that follow
that one big deceptive guy right okay
when a sales leader gets up and speaks
200 guys if you talk to your group as if
you're only trying to prove that
deceptive guy the negative guy wrong
you're going to lose your audience you
have to get up and talk to the 80
percent that are willing to have
somebody sell them the dream trump
stopped talking to people that were
open-minded and he only talked to his
enemies you got to get you got to forget
about the enemies that are going to be
there they're going to say what they're
going to say if you would have sold the
dream it would have been a little bit
more about hey america's great america
is this america's that that messaging
went away a little bit so look if trump
decides to go run again the messaging
would need to change a little bit
approach would need to change a little
bit because if he goes the same way
the results are going to be the same i
totally agree with that and here's the
other thing is part of his motivation
for running payback and getting revenge
and i have one more term i can do
whatever the hell what do you think i'd
say it definitely is an element involved
in that it's the same thing with cuomo
thinking about running for attorney
general it's probably the main reason
why he would want to you think it is a
revenge thing for trump what percentage
do you think is revenge for trump
between
13 to 24 here we go
i think about these things i don't throw
out random numbers sounds very random
but that is not random that is not
random there's a low and a high it's
like instead of saying 80 percent
76 but by the way i i don't think it's
13 i think it's a pretty high number
that is actually i think it's higher too
i don't think it's 13
i think it's you guys embarrass me watch
what i'm gonna do to you i think there's
an element of that taking place
yeah i think there's an element of that
taking place and i think there's the
other element you know what the other
element is you know what's the cool
thing about
somebody leaving you and talking trash
about you and then a year two years
later saying man freaking hey i missed
that guy i [ __ ] i don't want to say this
but you know
you know what i'm saying everything
ex-girlfriend that's right mary mary if
you're listening david loves you david
loves you he cries every day in front of
my office saying what do i need to do to
get her back if you're listening please
yeah i can explain the text messages
text messages get back to you that dm he
sent it out one girl it was a mistake go
ahead tyler i just i think one of the
best things that happened to trump was
getting kicked off of social media
because everybody hated trump they said
no no more mean tweets well now you
don't have them now trump's not out
there running his mouth all the time 24
hours a day unfiltered trump you lose
that so people like david said it's like
an ex-girlfriend they start to rethink
and say well it wasn't that bad yeah he
needs a different approach
you were at mar-a-lago recently right
yeah what's the vibe out there i mean
he's living there isn't he
fired up is what it was fired up and
uh lit up is what it was so
kellyanne was there jared was there it
was a american first policy institute
you know the whole uh
idea of
low taxes low regulation larry kudlow
was there was was more like a business
uh
principles than it was more about the
political stuff and i think trump gave a
90-minute speech you know what he looked
like he looked like he was campaigning
that's what it looked like all right
look i was campaigning so we're gonna
see what's gonna end up happening but uh
uh
confidence was pretty up there with a
lot of interesting influences question i
have a question if if say biden and
trump ran do you think on any party they
try to split the vote like they're any
break out and try to run what do you
mean like a ross perot style in terms of
more somebody
that's not oh i see you like
would the republican party split would
the democratic party split would both of
them split i say there's more of a
chance of it happening in 2024 than in
the past i think it's a possibility i do
listen here or which party then here's
listen here's what i'd like to see
here's what i'd like to see i think
as a strategist if you're a strategist i
consider myself a strategist where i'm
seeing what i would do if i'm giving any
kind of counsel to somebody right this
is a very good time for somebody to be a
hero
this is a very very good time for
somebody to come in and be a hero okay
and from coming from a place i'm saying
listen here's where i'm coming from this
is your campaign you know how
everybody's campaigning around obamacare
everybody is entitled to having health
insurance right forward or dream or
change or whatever right trump's was
make america great again you know you
know what the campaign should be
make america unified again something
about unify right so think about if
somebody ran on unification today and
they went up there and they said look
here's what i want to do let me tell you
what we differ in we different this this
this this fine let me tell you what we
agree on family kids
so are we going to let seven things that
we disagree on
outweigh the 98 things that we agree on
okay here's my goal you're not going to
like all the decisions i make because my
goal is to bring this more to the center
and unify right now we are either tilted
to the left or we're tilted to the right
here's the problem if you're tilted to
the left you keep doing circles if
you're tilted to the right you keep
those circles the only way they're going
to keep moving forward is to get a
little bit more to the center so i would
like to see somebody from like a
like i don't even want to say rock but i
would like to see somebody that's coming
in that is not afraid of losing a few
coup points from their side of the aisle
to say listen man unifying america is
more important than getting those cool
points from that's how you convert too
and it's bunch especially there's the
silent middle you need to win time right
now to do it oh my god people crave that
right right now to do it the thing is it
has to be authentic i don't think you
can just automatically
turn yourself into saying that this is
going to be who i agree so if someone
comes from that business background or
something that's inspiring and motiva
people want to hear that right now
they're craving it who would that be who
would that be to come that can give that
message well obama is one for sure you
think obama could unify well if he
wanted to i think he has that power
because he does have that type of
charisma and who is he who's he going to
knight
to carry that
i'm just thinking about people right now
that have the actual
gravitas to do it have the collateral
politically to do it and have the
personality
um no that's what i'm asking so i agree
with what you said about obama but who's
he gonna knight who's the person with
the gravitas and the thing that you're
talking about that obama can come and
say
it's got to be somebody very very close
to him that he trusts and it can't be
some random sound crazy that they throw
but you know who i think you know a lot
michelle no no
you know who i think would be great um
to to be able to do that and he has no
interest in doing that
it's and i listen hang tight before
people flip out
i think it's a person like rogan
i think that's the kind of a person that
could pull it off
i think it's a person with a personality
like him who
brought a bernie sanders in and he says
i think he makes sense
cool
and then he brought tulsi gabbard i
think she makes sense
and he is now in the center where he
pushes back and saying here's what i'm
trying to see if i'm going to fix myself
or not without relying hey i got good
after two days later
i think he could pull it off
but i don't think he has any interest in
doing that at all but it's a personality
like him
it can't be too ambitious of a person
because if it's too and i'm not saying
joe's not ambitious it's not the point
that he's not ambitious joe's living the
life that he wants to live today like
it's like when i was on the podcast with
him i'm like he's like i have no
interest to start a company you want me
to do more stuff add more stuff to my
plate no i'm good so he's a systematic
guy that he's living a life right now
that i bet is like his dream life yeah
he doesn't he has his buckets and he
fills them up with them but i think i
think he does very well with enemies i
think he does very well with uh
dealing with enemies i think he knows
how to uh bring the other person's guard
down i think he sat down with some of
the smartest guys in in the world
i don't know i think a personality like
that could pull it off
when you think about it candace owns
candace would be a trump type of a
personality shapiro it has to be
somebody who's not too
too uh confrontational but also they're
not willing to back away from it it's
more kind of question what i'm saying
you're coming in as yeah let's solve
this as opposed to i'm gonna prove why
a thick skin who's built something who
doesn't really care because they're
going to be attacked they have to give
away five to six years they
i don't know
listen
it would be a very funny campaign uh the
joe rogan experience you know president
rogan if he ran for office that would be
daily podcast from the white house
podcast number 310
you know him doing press conference with
smoking weed and it's just like hey how
you doing the only thing though
spotify would have to up his contract by
like a billion dollars oh my god
howard stern saying i need four years
off
i'll come back to you but i need about
four years up we'll see what happens
next four years but i think we need a
personality like that so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]